support is needed FEMA administrator
Deanne Criswell will travel with the
president and while in California the
president will be joined by Governor
Newsom and other elected officials the
president has been closely monitoring
the situation in California over the
past several weeks and is being
regularly briefed by his homeland
security team throughout this time he
has remained in close touch with the
governor and also local officials on the
ground as you all saw President Biden
approved Governors Newsome request for
an expedited major disaster declaration
Saturday evening providing Federal
support for debris removal emergency
protective measures and individual
assistance to survey whose homes have
been damaged or destroyed by the storm
and we have over 500 FEMA and other
Federal Personnel have already deployed
to California to support response and
Recovery operations and are working side
by side with the state to ensure all all
needs are indeed met on the ground this
Sunday the White House will commemorate
what would have been the 50th
anniversary of Roe v Wade vice president
Harris will travel to Florida to deliver
a major address on the fight for women
across America to have access to
reproductive care and make their own
health care decisions
50 years after the Supreme Court's 1973
decision in Roe v Wade Ultra Mega
Republican officials continue to push at
all levels of government for extreme
legislation rolling back women's
fundamental rights including a National
Abortion ban
at the state level more than 60
anti-choice bills have been produced for
the 2023 legislative session including
extreme proposals going as far as
threatening women with felony charges
for accessing care in stark contrast the
president and the vice president remain
committed to fighting these extreme
attacks on women and expanding access to
reproductive care however they possibly
can this Sunday the president will speak
about the fight to secure women's
fundamental right to reproductive Health
Care in the face of these attacks she
will talk about what's at stake for
millions of women across the country and
most importantly the need for Congress
to codify the protections of Roe in to
law the president and the vice president
and a strong majority of the American
people believe that women must be
empowered to make decisions about their
own lives and health care and that those
decision should not should never be
should not be politicized or
second-guessed by politicians
unfortunately that is exactly what
Republican officials are doing in
Congress despite the outcome of the
midterm elections in which millions of
Americans went to the polls just across
the country to protect women's
constitutional rights and reject extreme
proposal to sell out the middle class we
have seen House Republicans abuse their
narrow majority to take aim at the very
issues the American people care about
the most
in addition to attacking Women's Health
Care we've already seen House
Republicans try and undercut the
progress President Biden has made
rebuilding the economy from the bottom
up and the middle out
today we get we got our news of even
more progress tackling inflation
bringing costs down for Americans both
producer and consumer inflation has
fallen has now fallen for about six
months straight
and consumer spending remains strong
with retail sales in December about flat
when adjusted for inflation that adds up
to Historic progress President Biden
inherited an economic crisis and turned
it into the strongest two years of job
growth on record the United States just
hit the lowest unemployment rate in 50
years because of his economic plan again
his economic plan for the American
people is indeed working
but as president is fighting as he is
fighting to bring costs down more and
ensure that middle class families get a
fair Shake
House Republicans are advancing an
economic plan that will
take tax cuts for the rich
higher prices and cutting social media
as part of me cutting social social
security and cutting Medicare as well
their very first vote of the new
Congress was a bill to worsen inflation
and tax welfare for the rich
they want to impose an unprecedented tax
increase on middle-class families in the
form of a 23 sales tax in order to
provide even more tax giveaways to the
super rich and big corporations they're
going to vote to raise gas prices and
deprive Americans of relief at the pump
and they're threatening to kill millions
of jobs and and 401K plans by trying to
hold the debt limit hostage unless they
can again cut Social Security cut
Medicare cut Medicaid
so on this last point the president has
been clear he will not allow Republicans
to take the economy hostage or make it
make make working Americans pay the
price for their schemes to benefit the
wealthiest Americans and also special
interests with that I say this all the
time Josh I haven't seen you in a long
time
and you always tell me you've been here
okay bye good to see you Josh kick us
off please give it everything you just
laid out with regard to House
Republicans what is the White House seen
or heard from House Republicans that
gives you confidence that we can avoid a
default look we've been very very clear
and I'll say this again
um let me first say let me first say
this part that after after the midterm
elections the president was very clear
as per we saw a historic uh kind of a
historic um uh
historica when it comes to a Democratic
president in the in 60 years being able
uh to uh you know to have a successful
midterm when you look at what we saw in
the Senate and we look at that red wave
that never happened uh the president
said you know the American people spoke
very loudly and very clearly they want
to see us work in a bipartisan way so
the president is is wants to do that
he's looking to do that but also when
you think about the debt limit it is uh
you know we've been very clear the debt
limit has been something that has
happened three times if you look at just
the last Administration in a bipartisan
way it is something that should be happy
that should be done without conditions
there should be we should not be
negotiating around it uh it is the it is
the duty the basic duty of Congress to
get that done and so we're not going to
uh we're just not going to negotiate
about that because again it was done
under the last president
it was done uh three times again in a
bipartisan bipartisan way this is there
is no alternative to Congress uh
responsibility here to address uh the
debt ceiling uh treasury makes millions
of payments each day their system is
built to pay our country's bills on time
it's not set to make the United States
delinquent by paying our bills there is
a reason that treasury secretaries of
both parties if you think about it and
if you all remember rejected this
incredible risky and dangerous idea that
has never been tried before so it is
essential for Congress to recognize that
dealing with the debt ceiling is their
constitutional responsibility this is an
easy one this is something that should
be happening without conditions
just to make sure I understand do you
think House Republicans in this Congress
see their responsibilities the way that
you just outlined they should I just
laid out why they should they should
have their they should feel the
responsibility and I talked about this
yesterday I quoted the Chamber of
Commerce said it would have catastrophic
Economic Consequences a former Economist
to Republican Senators Rob Portman Marco
Rubio Mitt Romney called it a really bad
idea and disaster and in 2011 then
treasury secretary Tim Geithner called
it unworkable and harmful it is uh it is
the precedent has been for both parties
to come together and to get this done we
are talking about uh the the full the
full faith and credit of our country
and then secondly real fast
um help us understand given the
frequency with which President Biden
Works in Delaware
what is the case against having visitor
logs for his house so I'm I am going to
refer you to my wife the White House
Council they actually addressed this
they answered this question uh that you
are asking me I believe on Sunday and I
also believe the Secret Service put out
a statement so I would refer you uh to
those two statements that that came out
uh from from the White House
uh I'm actually gonna go around I got a
a lovely letter from Tamara Keith you're
you're president of the White House
Correspondents uh Association and she
asked that I go around so I'm gonna do
that okay Courtney thanks Karen I wanted
to ask about the FAA issue last week
because the ground stop that was called
the airports across the country when is
the president expecting to receive an
after action
so as dot said the issue was a damage
that database file with no evidence of a
Cyber attack so I want to be very clear
about this and you heard uh you heard
secretary Buda judge say that there is
going to be an after action report I
don't have a timeline for you to share
from here I would refer you to the
Department of Transportation but this is
something that we obviously take very
seriously when it comes to the safety of
Americans that is something who are
flying something that we make a priority
when the timeline of the action report I
would uh go I would refer to Department
of Transportation
also this year Congress will have to
reauthorize funding for the FAA is there
anything that the president wants to see
specifically in that bill that pertains
to what happened last week again that's
something as I mentioned last week that
happens every five years we're up this
is the time that uh uh that we're going
to see Congress act on this don't have
anything to share on specifics again as
you know this is something as I just
mentioned when it comes to the safety of
American people this is something that
is a priority for us we want to get to
the bottom of what occurred uh just days
ago not too long ago I don't have any
specifics on the action that Congress is
going to take I'm going to go wait to
the back go ahead uh wet West uh oh I'm
sorry I'm so sorry that's my bad sorry
hi Karen good afternoon thank you I'd
like to turn your attention to Nigeria
just a few days ago an absolutely
horrific story a Catholic priest in his
rectory early Sunday morning
was literally burned to death Bandits
burned the rectory and uh today as a
matter of fact Pope Francis asked the
world to pray for father Isaac Archie
question one two questions here one
will the bind Administration forcefully
condemn acts of violence against
Christians in Nigeria
let me just say we are saddened by the
senseless killing we have seen the
reports and we're certainly a saddened
by that we are monitoring the situation
as information develops and so we hope
the Nigerian authorities will quickly
bring the perpetrators to Justice and of
course we condemn violence of any kind
and so that is something that you've
heard me say many times from this Podium
and that is something that we will
continue to condemn follow up on that
how many more Nigerian priests have to
be so brutally murdered before Nigeria
is placed back on the countries of
particular concernless you know the
state Department's list that is
something I would refer you to the state
department about that particular list go
ahead nice
thank you uh on the this question that
was the debt limit which was a lot of
the talk in here uh the last couple of
days is there any way that
um the president would be willing if the
president meets with uh Congressional
leadership on other matters between now
and when uh secretary yellin says will
reach the we'll reach the default Point
uh will he entertain discussions at all
during meetings that may be on uh some
unrelated topic with members of Congress
about debt limit negotiations or will he
just sort of say no we're not going to
do this we're going to we'll discuss the
topic at hand but we won't talk about
negotiating over the deadline so let me
be clear I don't have a a meeting with
leaders to to read out at this time or
to announce but we've been really clear
we will not there will not be any
negotiations over the debt ceiling that
we will not do that it is there a
constitutional Duty you think about how
Congress has uh has dealt with the debt
ceiling for the past several decades it
is their responsibility their
constitutional responsibility to act and
so but more broadly speaking at the
start of this new Congress I've
mentioned this before and I'll mention
it again we're reaching out to all
members from from both sides of the
aisle so they make sure that we are
built they know who to reach out to when
it comes to the office of alleged
Affairs so that we continue to build
those relationships again in the past
there has been bipartisan cooperation to
address the debt ceiling and that's how
it should be it should not be used as a
political football that is not how we
should be moving forward here our
Outreach is deliberate to ensure
Congress knows that the debt ceiling
must be addressed again without
conditions but always I'm not going to
read out any specific meetings or any I
don't have anything else to read out
about the president meeting with
leadership
that Courtney just asked actually the uh
Sarah Schumer says that the FAA
administrator nomination is going to be
a priority uh in the coming weeks uh are
there and I understand that's a priority
for the president as well do you have
any other priority nominations that you
would like Senator Schumer and the
Senate Democrats to take up uh first so
let me just say we certainly welcome in
itiate Senator Schumer's a supportive
comments this weekend as you just
mentioned and look forward to working
together to confirm Phil Washington
specifically as FAA administer an
administrator let me just add that FAA
as as I just said to Courtney is a key
agency with crucial safety mandate and
the president has nominated an
experienced qualified candidate who
currently runs one of the busiest ports
airports in the world
to lead the agency and so we will
continue to work with Senator Schumer
Senator Cantwell and others to seek this
switch the Swift confirmation so clearly
that is important to us look we're going
to continue to uh as we talk as I talk
about the Swift swift confirmation not
just of the FAA administrator but many
other crucial high-qualified nominees to
serve across the administration and we
will be renominating a number of
officials in the upcoming weeks and when
we have updates to share we certainly
will will share that okay yeah
um you mentioned vice president Harris
is going to speak up on the anniversary
of the overturning of Roe v way is the
administration going to announce any
initiatives or policies for protecting
abortion access particularly to women
who um get their pills by mail so so let
me just say the Administration has taken
actions with our limited authorities to
expand access to care the president has
issued two executive orders if you've
heard you've heard myself talk about it
John Klein from the gender policy
Council has been here to talk about the
executive orders that the president has
put forward it is to safeguard access to
abortion and contraception ensure that
everyone has access to health care free
from discrimination defend the the right
to travel across state lines for medical
care protect the physical Safety and
Security of clinics providers and
patients and also earlier this month the
FDA announced an independent
evidence-based decision to expand access
to medication abortion through telepath
and at pharmacies but we've been very
clear the president has been very clear
the vice president has been very clear
the only way to restore the protections
of Roe is for Congress to pass a
national law codifying the right to
choose no executive action will actually
deal with that is the issue that I just
laid out we need to codify row and
that's what you're going to hear
continue to hear from the president and
from the vice president don't have any
any other specific actions than what I
just laid out
okay uh who else taught uh thank you
um on the president's visit to the
Border last week is there any follow-up
any new uh policies has he spoken with
Governor Abbott to uh to follow up on
the governor's request don't have a I
don't have a um a conversation or a call
to read out I do want to say I've been
asked about if we've seen an impact from
what the president laid out a couple
weeks ago of what he's the actions that
he was taking at the border I want to
say that we are seeing some impact the
numbers of migrants arriving from those
countries are low and we look forward to
sharing more once we have more data to
go off of additionally the first
individuals authorized to to live and
work legally in the United States under
the expanded program started arriving
just last Tuesday within five days after
the launch of the program hundreds more
have been vetted and approved for travel
and can book a flight to the United
States to arrive on time but I want to
be very clear again uh we need Congress
to take action the president has done
what he can has uh from uh from his
using his uh from the executive from uh
from the White House but you know what
we're seeing is Congress still refuses
to act uh the president is going to use
every talk tools available as you have
seen him do these past two years uh to
deal to manage a mass migration event
impacting the entire Western Hemisphere
but just only but not only just one city
right we've seen it just across the
board so he's taking the steps he's
going to uh continue to take this very
seriously we think about the border
security but again Congress needs to act
Republicans need to act and if they
really care about this issue this is an
opportunity uh to reach across the aisle
and work with us on this
okay
oh my gosh good thanks thank you I want
to reference an interview that President
Biden did in mid-september with 60
minutes and in that interview he chided
former president Trump for having in his
possession classified documents he
called it irresponsible first of all do
you think it was proper for President
Biden
to comment on an ongoing doj
investigation so I'm going to say this
and I'm going to keep it really short
today as it relates to this particular
issue as it relates to an ongoing legal
matter I'm going to refer you to
Department of just Department of Justice
without that specific as it relates to
anything that you want to ask of us
about uh this uh this legal matter I
would refer you to the White House
Council Office I'm going to leave it
there not going to go into further
I just commented I just commented we're
moving on go ahead go ahead go ahead go
ahead go ahead no go ahead I already
answered your question go ahead
well I I did well it's your it's your
opinion it's your opinion it's your
opinion that is your opinion go ahead go
ahead go ahead I have two domestic
questions today first of all can you
just walk us through the administration
of rationale who won in South Carolina
and your reaction to
effect
um look we have addressed this the
depart uh the Democratic National
Committee has addressed this I'm just
not going to go any further to what
we've already shared about this uh so
I'm just gonna leave it to uh the
statements that we put out just a couple
of weeks ago on the process I'm just not
going to dive into the process from here
take another stab at it but
um with we don't know what's in these
documents but can the U.S and is the U.S
working to reassure allies and partners
that you can still participate in
intelligence gathering and still be
trusted with Secrets is that are those
conversations that the president is
having right now or the top of
administration officials are having for
example Jake Sullivan in Israel I'm
going to say this the president takes
classified information seriously you
heard that directly from him to classify
documents seriously you heard that
directly from him last week and I'm just
going to leave it there I'm not going to
open this up for discussion we have
answered many questions when it is as it
is related to uh to the documents any
specifics that's related to this the
uh this review this legal process I
would refer to Department of Justice and
any questions that you may have of us I
would refer you to my colleagues at the
White House council's office so I'll
leave it there okay go ahead Joey go
ahead
um the president is scheduled to meet on
Friday with a group of Mayors can you
just give us a preview of that meeting
how many mayors uh what's on the agenda
uh what's the president's message what
does he hope to accomplish so as you
know he's going to as you just mentioned
he's going to meet with uh mayor's
bipartisan Mayors who are attending the
U.S Conference of Mayors this is
something that the president certainly
is looking forward to to attending and
to uh to interact with the Mayors who
will be who will be here don't have any
more specifics as the list certainly as
we get closer we will be sharing a list
with all of you and more information
about about the remarks that he will be
giving but again it's a Bible it's going
to be bipartisan Mayors and opportunity
as president has said and he has said
during his Senate years as a vice
president and as during the campaign and
now as president he looks forward to
working a bipartisan way and continuing
to deliver for the American people and
that's what uh and that's what you're
you're probably hear from him uh on
Friday but don't have don't want to get
beyond that uh haryana and way in the
back I'm gonna go way in the back
it's been over a month since the U.S
Africa Leadership Summit take place and
I would like you to give us an update
what have been done so far in order to
accomplish all the agreements and
projects that being agreed upon during
the summit no it's a very good question
look President Biden was very pleased
with the summit and its outcome
including his personal engagement with
many of his counterparts that week the
summit was an effective demonstration of
our renewed partnership with the regions
governments business community and
silver Civil Society as well as the
broader African diaspora the president
and the African leaders work together to
define a shared Global agenda and to set
the stage for a deeper cooperation and
engagement in 2023 and Beyond so it is
it was just the beginning and we're
looking to uh we're truly looking to
continue those conversations clearly on
the staff level as we continue
throughout the year
portion of the classroom it's how the
president is feeling is he worried about
those documents that were found or is he
did he somehow regret to
to what he have done with those
documents and being found at his
property is his uh worried about that
but first
I'm gonna repeat what I've just said
moments ago he takes this very seriously
when it comes to classified documents
when it comes to classified information
He was unaware uh that the documents
were there you heard that directly from
him from the president twice he spoke to
this uh just last week and his team is
fully cooperating uh with this process
with the legal this ongoing legal
process uh anything specific dealing
with this uh dealing with this uh with
this issue I would refer to Department
of Justice or the special counsel and
I'll leave it there okay I'll come I'll
come down I'll come down again thank you
I appreciate it um the White House State
put out this really sharply awarded
statement about the committee
assignments the oversight committee
assignments Mark Taylor green
representative Go Star representative
assignment to the Riverside committee
the statement said handing the keys
oversight to the most extreme Mega
members in the Republican caucus who
promote violent rhetoric and dangerous
conspiracy theories given the statement
does the White House view the oversight
committee as even legitimate so look
I've been very clear and I just said
this moments ago the president intends
to work with both parties in good faith
if they choose to and make more progress
on on behalf of the American people he
has said this we will continue to say
this but unfortunately to your point
Mary on some of these key committees it
appears that House Republicans have
handed over the keys to the most extreme
Mega members of the Republican caucus
this is what we're seeing from the other
side of Pennsylvania Pennsylvania Avenue
these are members who have promoted
violent rhetoric and dangerous
conspiracy theories including suggesting
violence against political opponents
trafficking in anti-semitic lies and
defending and downplaying a violent
Insurrection against our democracy you
all many of you covered what we saw on
January 6 2021
and so Republican leaders should explain
they should have to explain not us they
should have to explain why allowing
these individuals to serve on these
committees and come clean with the
American people about this the secret
agreements the secret deals that were
made with these extreme Mega uh Mega
extremists in that are currently uh in
in the house and so that is something
for them to respond to that is some that
question goes to them sounds like you
don't view the committee is very I I
that did not say that I laid out uh I
laid out what the president intends to
do I laid out
um what uh what unfortunately what the
actions that they have taken how
unfortunate it is to basically hand over
the keys to some of the most extreme uh
people uh in the in the Republican Party
the Maga ultramaga Republicans and what
they've done but it is not for me to
answer that question it is for them to
answer why is it that they chose to move
in that direction and can I just about
what you just said earlier about the
president being surprised the documents
were even there he said multiple times
you've said again he was unaware and
these classified documents were even in
his garage and his residence given that
given that that you could actually just
be surprised that documents were there
does that suggest to you to this white
house that reform is needed there needs
to be changes for how classified
documents are tracked through the US
government I'm not I'm not in a position
to talk about reform or how this process
should go forward uh what I will say is
this is something that's being reviewed
by the Department of Justice I would
refer you to them I refer you to the
special counsel I'm just not going to go
any further than that
so much uh I would have two questions
one is
the economy on Ukraine
um The Wall Street Journal and the
German newspapers are now reporting that
the Germans won't provide science for
Ukraine unless the US does exactly the
same so this seems to be a kind of
Deadlock situation here what's the
administration doing about it so um I
was asked this question yesterday when
it comes to uh the U.S we're in constant
communication with Ukraine and we'll
continue to provide them with what they
need as they defend themselves against
Russian aggression and against this
brutal war that we have seen from Russia
for almost a year now but I don't have
any new announcements to share of any
types of security assistance to preview
look when it comes to uh when it comes
to other countries the president
believes that each country can should
make their own Sovereign decisions on
what steps of security assistance and
what kinds of equipment they are able to
provide Ukraine as again Ukraine defends
itself against Russian aggression so for
instance we welcome Germany's recent
announcement that they will send
infantry uh fighting vehicles and a
Patriot missiles battery system to
Ukraine we also support the decision by
the UK over the weekend to send
Challenger tanks to Ukraine and we have
seen incredible solidarity by Nations
around the world to support Ukraine so
but it's not for us to speak to that is
there each country's decision to make
that uh to make their own Sovereign
decisions on this as it relates to the
U.S we have been as you know the largest
provider of security assistance of a
humanitarian Aid we will we will be
standing by with the Ukrainian people
and uh and helping them in any way that
they that we can to defend themselves uh
until you know until uh throughout
throughout this process but I don't have
any announcements to make at this time
the the president has been like quite
optimistic in his latest statements
about you know the possibility of a soft
Landing for the economy but at the same
times we also have like a massive layer
of announcements like Microsoft just
today is this uh matter of concern for
the White House so that is something
um as you know that we watch closely
anytime there are reports of Americans
losing their jobs
President Biden knows firsthand the
impact of losing a job and what that can
have to your entire family this is
something that he knows and understands
very well I don't have a comment on
specific moves announced by particular
companies as you know we are we're very
careful from here talking about private
companies but more broadly speaking
layoffs remain near record lows
according to job openings data we found
that we found out this week that 10
million new small businesses have been
created since President Biden took
office I talked about this from this
Podium just yesterday in simile third
quarter GDP revision shows that the U.S
economy continues to grow and add jobs
we've also seen companies like T tsmc
IBM and Hyundai announced or Hyundai
announce new Investments doubling down
on building Technologies of the future
like chips and Ai and electric vehicles
in the U.S companies across the economy
are continuing to grow and invest in the
United States but again of course this
is something that we watch very closely
okay go ahead
thank you so much and welcome back thank
you China reported that its economic
growth fell to three percent last year
and its population dropped for the first
time since 1961. is the administration
concerned about China's relative
economic weakness and do you think that
this raises the likelihood of an
economic downturn in the U.S and the
global economy this year so look I'm not
going to comment on uh how China handles
its own economy but what we are focused
on is our approach which has uh to
ensure that the United States economy
remains resilient and that's the
president's focus and we're talking
about resilience we're talking about
resilience in the face of global
challenges and has helped spur a
historic recovery that is what we have
seen in This president's first two years
uh as uh Indian of his administration
will continue our work to make progress
on reducing prices and investing in our
infrastructure manufacturing and clean
injury energy economy and so we of
course monitor all Global development
and will continue to stay in touch with
our partners allies and key Market
sectors including China as you have have
you have seen secretary secretary Yellen
isn't is in China and she's going to be
meeting with China's vice president on
one Wednesday one Wednesday which is
today and so again she's there currently
right now in China and there have been
more allegations about Congressman
George Santos's misuse of finances of
course this is in addition to him
fabricating key details of his
background while running for office
prompting more calls from both parties
for his resignation just wanted to check
back in does the White House think he
should resign so look we have we we've
said this before and I think I said it
the the
probably the first few days of this a
minute of this new Congress in this new
year which is it is up to it is up to
the Republican conference who have to
decide what they owe the American people
it is their decision to make uh on on
what it means uh what they see as it
relates to the terms of standards and
service they have to decide that it is
their conference he's part of their
conference clearly but sadly we have
seen that they feel they owe the
American people when it comes to
standards by the actions that they have
taken on this particular individual look
um you know just looking at the
committee that he has been assigned to
when it comes to Biden's economic plan
and when it comes to the announcement
that I made yesterday when it comes to
small business we have seen a business
application with over 10 million new
small businesses created under this
leadership and so the president takes
that very seriously he takes uh he takes
build making sure that we're building an
economy from the bottom up the middle
out very seriously and you see that in
every part of his policies and every
economic policy that he pushes forward
but again this is up to the Republican
conference to show what they think they
owe the American people so it's their
decision to make
just a quick follow-up on the economy
and job Cuts Amazon announced 18 000 job
Cuts today Microsoft announced 10 000
job Cuts today all these thousands of
job cuts are coming on top of tens of
thousands of jobs being cut across the
tech sector and across sectors uh in
Corporate America obviously the White
House on the administration like you
just you know pointed out a couple of
minutes ago still believes the economy
is resilient does not expect it to slip
into a recession but as we talk about
Mass layoffs and as the White House
continues to point a strong economy and
overall recovery in the labor market how
do you expect some of these numbers and
some of these statistics to impact that
recovery in the country so let me just
be clear when you talk about recession
and you talk about what we're seeing
currently with the economy these are the
data points right this is the data
points are showing that this is not what
we see right with the economy is
currently to a pre-recession or
recession I mean that is what the
experts are saying as well and that's
what the data points are proving with
CPI today the consumer that CPI the PPI
today we're seeing that inflation is
actually indeed moderating and a lot of
that is connected to the president's
economic policies and so that is
something that we're going to continue
to highlight we're going to continue to
point to the data not just our words but
that's what the data is showing look
again as I mentioned to your colleague
I'm not going to comment specifically
on on what's currently happening with
particular companies with private
companies clearly we're closely
monitoring but like I said layoffs
remain near record lows according to the
job openings data again looking at the
data looking at the numbers we found out
again I talked about the small
businesses 10 million new small
businesses have been created since the
president took office that matters those
data points also matter the third
quarter GDP revision shows that the US
economy continues to grow and add jobs
so that's what I will point you to in
answering your question as I just laid
out but again we are seeing an econ
we're seeing the present Economic Policy
actually working and I think that's
important as well is there more work to
do always more work to do and you hear
that from us as well maybe a concern
from these uh tens of thousands of what
I'm saying is we're going to closely
monitor this or you know we are always
keeping an eye on these things but but
these are private uh these are private
companies that are making decisions and
we're just not going to comment
in China
um you were talking about secretary
Yellen in a treasury announced today
that she's planning to go to China a
secretary of state is planning to go to
China the president met what she in uh
Bali in November uh clearly there is
sort of momentum in you know some sort
of uh rebuilding of ties between the two
Nations going forward this year should
we expect the administration on the
White House perhaps tone down its
rhetoric against China and really focus
on rebuilding the relationship between I
think we've been very clear on our
approach with China that hasn't changed
we're looking for a competition right
that's what we're that's what we that's
how we see our relationship with China
uh and uh you know that hasn't changed
it's not going to change when we walked
in when the president walked into the
administration in 20 in 2021 is
certainly not going to change in 2023.
good Karen I actually have an answer for
you uh on the question you asked me
yesterday yeah
okay yes okay but if you have a response
this is the New Mexico I believe right
yeah okay so the allegations uh here are
horrifying and shocking and it's a
miracle that no one was hurt uh the
president has spoken out repeatedly and
emphatically about how our nation
rejects violence as a political tool
that is a Bedrock principle of our
democracy it is important for leaders in
both parties to reaffirm that particular
that particularly as we've seen an
increase in violent rhetoric and
political violence like we've seen most
recently again in New Mexico this
Administration has also emphasized the
dangerous ways in which conspiracy
theories and disinformation can lead
some individuals to violence again we
urge leaders in both parties to reject
lies and conspiracies and finally let me
add it's worth emphasizing that those
intending to use violence as a political
tool often choose Firearms to intimidate
and inflate Carnage and so that is why
this is Administration has made strides
to address firing arms but also has
urged more to be done against our our
it's a horrifying and shocking and we're
just we're just glad that no one was
hurt in this in this event and if I can
also ask you I asked you last Friday and
I know that there was a formal request
from the whca to have Richard silver
come to the briefing and take questions
to follow up on that would you commit to
having the White House Council come here
and take questions that is something
that I would refer you to the White
House counsel's Office this is they have
been engaged with all of you I know
again they did a 45-minute call with
many of if not you many of your
colleagues somebody had somebody here
had said 30 30 minutes but it was not it
was actually 45 minutes they miscounted
and so that was important they will
continue to engage with all of you and
so again I would refer you to the White
House council's Office on this and any
specifics to the ongoing legal matter I
would refer to Department of Justice
I am happy I'm happy to pass it along
I have two questions one on Nato one on
Belarus there's an impasse between
Sweden Finland and turkey over ankara's
demands related to swedens and finland's
NATO accession so I'm wondering if you
consider those demands reasonable and if
not does the president
consider turkey a reliable NATO Ally and
the second question on Belarus a trial
of a prominent police Belarusian
activist Andre potawat has started in
Belarus yesterday and he's facing 12
years in prison for just criticizing
lukashenka's regime can you comment on
that and is there anything that the U.S
can do to help to press Belarus on this
so let me just say that we do see turkey
as a reliable Ally so I'll answer that
question that you just asked me on
anything specific about uh about the
agreement and what's currently happening
we would refer you to the Turkish
government to speak on their own
position that's not something that I
will do for them I would not speak for
them here what I can say is that we have
been a strong supporter of Finland and
Sweden's applications for NATO
membership and worked with the Senate to
move quickly to ratify their
applications you saw you all were here
and saw Finland and Sweden's leadership
here with the president not too long ago
we have welcomed the rapid ratifications
by our allies and we urge all remaining
allies to complete their own
ratification process as quickly as
possible to your question about Belarus
so we condemn uh the regime's blatant
attempts to intimidate and harass
peaceful protesters members of the
democratic oppositions journalists
unionists activists human rights
Defenders and ordinary belarusians these
politically motivated trials are just
the latest examples of the regime's
effort to intimidate and repress those
who seek Justice respect for human
rights and Democratic Belarus and a
democratic Belarus I should say the
response to respond to these human
rights abuses the state department
recently took action to impose visa
restrictions on 25 individuals for their
involvement in undermining belarus's
democracy the U.S the United States
stands firmly with Belarusian people and
their Democratic aspirations I'm going
to keep going
um to be clear my question about
procedures here at the White House and
not about anything specific related to
the doj investigation
um so I'm just wondering how this
episode has prompted a review of the
process in which staffers handle
classified information
and how they are turned over to National
Archives during a transition and to be
clear I'm going to refer you to the what
my colleagues at the White House
counsel's office they will be able to
address that particular questions I'm
just not going to address something that
is even related to an ongoing legal
process
I mean I'm having a hard time
understanding why I just said questions
about we show procedure and I just said
and I just said to you the White House
counsel's office will be able to address
that question
is provide and satisfied with the
current sop of handling classified
materials here and turning them over to
National Archives again I will refer you
to the White House council's office they
are the they're the people who would uh
be able to answer that question about
classify you're from this point on are
you not going to be taking questions
about the classified doctor I have been
very clear over and over again we are
going to be prudent here we're going to
be consistent this particular matter is
being uh is being looked at there's a
legal process currently happening at the
Department of Justice and I'm going to
refer you to the Department of Justice
on any specifics too this particular
case and anything that has to deal with
um are what we're doing here I would
refer to the White House counsel's
office and let me remind you this is
this is this is not a new process here I
we've been doing this for the past two
years anything that is related to a
legal process a legal matter we refer to
the Department of Justice there's
nothing new in our process here great
thank you
um
since so many of our questions have been
referred to the doj and to the White
House council's office I'm sure you can
understand that we're in sort of
information blackout where doj refers us
to the special counsel they're not
holding any briefings White House
counsel refers to doj so
if you are not able to talk about this
from the podium would you invite a doj
official to take our questions here to
the briefing no you would have to go to
the Department of Justice that is not
this is a a legal matter that is
currently happening at the Department of
Justice and the president has been very
very clear when it comes to these types
of legal matters when it comes to
investigations he's not going to
interfere he wants to make sure that we
give back the Independence that the
department Justice should have when it
comes to these types of Investigations
so certainly would not be bringing them
here so I would refer you to the
Department of Justice I I just I I was
just very clear if you have any
questions I would refer to the White
House counsel's office they did a call
for 45 minutes yesterday speaking to
many of you I believe there were more
than 200 people on that call and so I
would refer you to my colleagues at the
White House counsel's Office
but on questions that you should be able
to answer here that shouldn't have to go
to any other agency or entity can you
tell us if there's any sort of
assessment that has been planned or
launched to determine if National
Security has been jeopardized at all
again that's another department why is
it a deal and let's be clear it's not
your decision to make of what I can or
can't answer from here what I'm telling
you is that we are respecting the
process we are being prudent from here
there is an investigation currently
happening and when there is when there
are investigations that are happening
that the doj is currently reviewing or
looking at we have been very consistent
to say that you need to go to the
Department of Justice with NSC or with
any other intelligence again I would
refer you I would it's very it's it's
very clear is I I just laid out there is
no there should be no confusion here
either there is a legal process
happening and I would refer to the
Department of Justice
we've all reached out to the Department
of Justice the law enforcement official
tells NBC News the justice department
has not told the White House that it
cannot talk about the facts underlying
the special counsel investigation into
classified documents so trusting you've
received that same information
understanding the desire to be prudent
then why why can't speak about the
underlying facts we've been very clear
when it comes to even underlying facts
when it comes to specifics when it comes
to something that is under the purview
that is that the Department of Justice
is looking at especially legal matters
investigations we do not comment from
here Peter that has been consistent
we've been very consistent Bob Bauer who
represents the president's personal
attorney over the weekend said that one
of the reasons why in Ian Sam's your
colleague who represents who speaks on
behalf of the special counsel at the
White House spoke to this in some form
yesterday but he said one of the reasons
why they shouldn't reveal uh further
details right now was regular ongoing
public disclosures also pose the risk
that is further in information develops
answers provided on this periodic basis
may be incomplete when the White House
did release a statement the president
spoke out on January 9th
the risk of incompletion was a function
of the White House's decision not to
share all the information it knew in
fact because we knew on
November 2nd and the first discovery was
made we knew the second Discovery was
made on December 20th so there's a risk
of incompletion but will you concede
that it's the white house that has been
incomplete in its provision of
information when it did choose to speak
out possible in January my colleague
actually dealt with this question on the
call yesterday on the White House
council's office
and I would refer you to the White House
counselves Then is the White House
having any conversations internally
about finding someone much the same way
John Kirby has spoken on behalf of
National Security issues at this Podium
as your colleague as their
representative israelman is the White
House in talks right now to find someone
either outside the White House or
internally who can speak on behalf of
the White House representing the special
counsel office within the White House
from this Podium or any of those talks I
would refer you to the White House
council's Office but you're the
communications
you as a Communications matter having
weeks there is existing Peter you have
spoken to my colleague who did again a
45-minute call with all of you answering
questions about uh
not on the record until the call ends
that means the American people can't see
it in public so we're asking will there
be a representative who may speak on
Cameron state in public but his the Paul
was indeed he was quoted it was in in
papers it was on networks correct but
because they can't witness it happening
live Americans don't get the same
transparency into this back and forth I
think I think some is the White House
having a conversation Peter Peter this
is just with respect you guys brought
John Kirby and I'm asking if that
conversation exists the fact that he
spoke to all of you reporters who report
on this and then you all reported on it
back to the American people I believe
that is transparency I believe that he
shared information he answered your
questions that you believe that the
American people wanted to hear and he
answered those questions and he took he
took 45 minutes to do that anything
anything else that you have on this
Peter I would refer to the White House
Council Peter I'm not we just went back
Peter
I just I actually just answered that
question I said we have someone
currently right
we have someone currently who answered
your questions for 45 minutes on a call
and took your questions took your
questions about this particular issue
he will continue to do that he will
continue to engage with all of you right
on this issue on this legal process
that's currently happening from the
White House council's office after that
Peter I don't have anything else to
share okay go ahead go ahead last
question on the um debt limit I know
that the White House says if you're not
going to negotiate with Republicans on
sort of
sessions or anything tied to it does
that mean that the White House the
president is is dissuading other
Democrats on the Hill from engaging in
those conversations and those
negotiations with Republicans well we've
been very clear about is that in the
last Administration the debt ceiling was
dealt with three times three times in a
bipartisan way and so that's what the
president wants to see that is a that is
a it is their um uh constitutional Duty
for Congress to deal with this issue and
again it's been done in a bipartisan way
and we should not put the full faith and
credit uh of uh of of our country and
take it a hostage right we should not do
that and so that's what we've been very
clear about it's been done in a
bipartisan way the last three times
under three times under the last
Administration and that's what we want
to see just to be clear Democrats and
Republicans and a bipart is something
like reaching understanding reach an
agreement as it relates to the debt
limit the president
we've been we've been very clear there
should not be any negotiations around
here we should not be stepping around uh
dealing with the debt ceiling we've been
incredibly clear here this is an issue
that is a constant the basic the basic
duties of Congress to take care of to
handle uh and so uh we're going to be
continue to say that we're going to be
very clear it should be done without
conditions thank you everybody
[Music]
at home
[Music]